as you probably know 20 20 20 has
brought a lot of change also to my
personal life
definitely didn't see anything coming
that came that's kelly clarkson
addressing her split from brandon
blackstock
during the season two premiere of the
kelly clarkson show on monday
the singer who filed for divorce from
her hubby of seven years
in june opened up about the hardest part
what i'm dealing with is hard because it
involves more than just
my heart it involves a lot of little
hearts you know we have
four kids and divorce is never easy um
and we're
both from divorce families so you know
we we know the best thing here is to
protect our
our children and their little hearts i
think uh being a parent you learn more
about yourself
rather than your children i wanted to be
independent and i wanted to be
strong and and just grateful and
appreciative of humans
kelly went on to tell her virtual
audience that although she's
normally an open book she probably won't
go
too far into discussing her divorce i'm
a mama bear and my kids come first the
38 year old shares two kids with black
stock
six-year-old river rose and
four-year-old remington alexander
she's also stepmother to his daughter
and son from a previous marriage
eighteen-year-old savannah and
thirteen-year-old seth
we're a very american family in the
sense of like
you know there's a lot of different
families going on
everybody keeps asking are you okay are
you okay and i am the answer is yes
the tv personality assured her fans that
she's doing
okay and opened up about how she used
music to cope when her own parents
divorced
when i got upset when i was a kid i had
a problem like saying
how i felt and my mom told me to start
writing and that's actually
how i get my feelings out and that's how
i became a songwriter music's always
been my outlet to help me get through
difficult times e.t was with kelly when
she launched her eighth
studio album meaning of life back in
2017.
i'm in an amazing point in my life i
think once i turned 30 like my whole
life
just my shoulders relaxed like
everything was like okay so you just
want to make sure you're happy and you
love what you're doing and
and this album is literally the chapter
of my life that is like
i'm blessed man but since then things
seemingly took a turn
with the source telling e.t in june that
kelly and brandon
had been having problems for several
months adding that the couple
hoped that quarantining away from la and
montana
would help them work things out in their
marriage but instead
the change in environment was actually
detrimental
in the end the source says kelly quote
knew she just needed to follow her heart
and finally realized divorce was her
only option
the source added that both kelly and
brandon are heartbroken
but are focusing on co-parenting and
moving forward
we're definitely a team